la música ensaya es el nombre del primer
gran concierto realizado en chile desde
el inicio de la pandemia de kobe 19
organizado por la sociedad chilena de
autores intérpretes musicales y la
universidad de chile
pero tiene otra particularidad
hace parte de un ensayo clínico que
busca medir el impacto de los conciertos
en la propagación del coronavirus 200
voluntarios asistieron al recital del
grupo chancho en piedra
emocionante espero mucho tiempo juego
con música en vivo
y de verdad
la sala fue equipada de medidores de co2
sistemas de ventilación y un estricto
protocolo sanitario para los asistentes
que debían portar mascarillas dar
pruebas de vacunación y mostrar
resultados recientes de pruebas pcr una
esperanza de apertura para un sector
fuertemente golpeado por la pandemia
el estudio de este ensayo clínico
inédito en latinoamérica va a sentar los
presentes para que pueda volver la
música a los escenarios cambiarla
artescénica una semana después del
concierto los asistentes se someterán a
nuevas pruebas pcr esperamos los
resultados nos permitan avanzar a un
segundo evento con un mayor aforo y
posteriormente un tercer evento que será
el definitivo y final y con esos
resultados nosotros vamos a ir al
ministerio de salud 1,6 millones de
personas se han infectado con kobe 19 en
chile y más de 45 mil fallecieron según
el ministerio de salud pero pese a todo
el país tuvo una exitosa campaña de
inoculación con más de 80 por ciento de
la población con un esquema de
vacunación completo